[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
cecil
dc the brian supreme
a brain supreme todd you can't spell
brain
i misspelled it um
steve uh rock and roll gibson they're
known as a tag team you see them
in uh the geico commercial dc and steve
joining us on the program
i'm going great uh thanks for joining us
on the program
um how wild has this ride been this
month
uh it's been fun really hasn't been a
ride we're used to it
um we've been doing this forever man so
we're just
happy to be blessed and happy to
continue on bringing happiness to
everybody in the world
take me back to what is the early 90s
and who came up with the idea for the
song
all right so i heard you in before the
break and you got that totally wrong
wait i wait cinnamon was not involved in
this or chocolate
wait a minute i'm gonna tell you the
story okay okay okay back then
it was a popular saying right so it's
kind of like lit it was
or any popular catch phrase there are
going to be a whole bunch of people that
make songs about it right
so in my situation we used to say it at
a club i used to work at as the dj
called magic city in atlanta georgia how
are the wings
the wings are wonderful that's what i
thought so
you know i remember you know we used to
just party and it was one day it's
called midshift
around 7 p.m it was chocolate cinnamon
dark and lovely cocoa vogue uh
and several other girls it just it just
kind of erupted
and it just kept going right and we had
been doing it but i never paid attention
to it
and then it just went on a night shift
with vanity sparkle
tinkled so you understand so it's
basically a party
record in the club the customers love it
the guys loved it
and i knew being in the southeast we had
to make
something up tempo so i went to steve
and them the rusty uh he came to me and
said hey
we need to make a song called won't
there it is like
how do you spell it and he told me how
to spell it right
and then after that uh he told me hey
man it has to be a uh
up tempo track some down south stuff and
i'm like wait a minute man we're from
denver
i don't know how to make that he said
well you don't have to
man he said do it your way and um
and then from there man he told me he
said hey man just remember planet rock
and
egyptian lover egypt egypt and all that
type of stuff just some up temple stuff
you know
and that's when i put the beat together
and uh we went to the studio
we laid it down and shoot the rest was
history man
okay but when it's whoop there it is
are the are the strippers taking off
their clothes is that where it's
strippers are already naked
all right naked and see back then it
wasn't about making it rain or throwing
money it was about who had the biggest
garter belt
so if the girl's garter belt looked like
an afro on their leg
that was the girl that had the that had
the most juice and had the most money
that's a historical
fact i i i knew this by the way get off
of this
wait this this this is part of the story
this is what makes the story
i know geico's gonna like this
i think you're all set when when did you
know you had something
um i left the studio and it was on a
we mixed it down to a cassette tape
for all you youngins out there cassette
tape was right after the eight track
tape but before
the cd right now you just popped it in
exactly computer not a not a laptop
yeah exactly and i popped it in
uh the tape because i was a dj i set up
popped it in and i played it
and to this day that is the biggest
response i've had
as a dj on any record i've ever played
at least 10 to 15 people came was like
man what is that
and i knew you know and we had had other
songs and other songs done well so i
kind of sat on it for a while i didn't
really realize what i had
and then uh one of the girls was like
how come you don't play whoop there it
is anymore
and i was like i'll play it for you and
i played it again
and it was the same thing and then one
of the record reps
uh alan cole was like man give me that
you know i'm gonna take that to new york
and let them hear it and then
shopped it for a deal and then uh we got
with bellmark records
and i left magic i gave my two weeks of
magic city left freak nick
93 and a month and a half we were
platinum
and it went platinum a few times uh
steve uh
when when did they uh when did you hear
about maybe they wanted to do a uh
commercial with you guys like how did
that
uh come up um actually they sent
dc an email and he he sends me all the
emails because he has
our business account so um he sent me
the email
and we discussed it man and said hey
let's keep our mouth shut before we blow
it
because if you get to talking too much
you're going to blow it man
and we agreed upon that and
everything happened for us man and we're
grateful for it
how many takes oh man
it was on that shoot it was all day
shoot but it was cool for me
because i'm an actor and a voice artist
right so
this was part for the course for me
right but um
steve can explain how it was for him man
it was
exhausting to me man when i went home i
went to sleep
and slept all night like a baby man
i was exhausted we did we danced so much
that day man it was like
oh man i never danced that much man
there's a million takes of it yeah i i
love the
the sprinkles you know what that's from
don't you
you know what that you know a sport
that's from a sports uh that's like a
sports analogy right
and you know when lebron goes to the
table before he comes in
and does the chalk yeah okay that's
sprinkles that that's so you're giving a
shout out to lebron shout out to lebron
james because
he inspired the sprinkles but cinnamon
but cinnamon and chocolate came up
they they inspired the song
[Laughter]
and dr lovely
is there a sequel is there a sequel in
the works steve
uh no not right now um
yeah man we kind of you know hey it's
not it should be
it should be more more sequels a lot
more
um whoever wants to do them let's do
them
yeah and you know what's great is you
got a younger generation you got young
kids
you know my guys their kids they just
walk around
and they probably don't even know that
they're singing you know peanut butter
cookie dough but but they're
they're doing it i mean it's it's really
catchy we're actually about to do
a scoop there it is challenge ooh where
everybody
you know i've been getting a lot of
videos where people record their babies
in front of the tv and then when the
commercial goes off the baby starts
screaming and playing again
so they sit there rewinding it over and
over and over again the babies just
don't even notice you don't have to walk
like we've been babies first step
because of this commercial because they
find a way to get up on the tv and just
start dancing
so we might do a scoop there it is
challenge and the winter
i don't know if i'm gonna do some
t-shirts i'm gonna do i don't know what
i'm gonna do but
we're gonna do something so be on the
lookout for the scoop there this
challenge
no it's great it's fun and uh oh yeah
definitely but but don't you have
uh the people in the background doing
kid and play aren't they uh
the pair that's uh that's nikki and uh
uh anthony anthony anthony right
and i love that part because their kid
in fl
play is flawless i was like whoa
and you know all that stuff was really
like impromptu man we just did it on the
spot man
so uh yeah can you give me a little
uh can you give me a little taste here
before uh i say goodbye
uh-uh got the commercial no no no
no no no no all right
there you go stephen
steve i was waiting for you oh i'm
taking it back to the old school
because i was going to kick it so cool i
was going to kick in there a little bit
you know you want to get down oh you
know me
i went to gold club i went to gold club
in atlanta
never magic city i know yeah i used to
go to gold club too
yeah we all used to go
that's where i first met porsha and
cinnamon
and sprinkles and tiffany
to the main stage to the main stage
[Laughter]
hey congrats guys uh thanks for joining
us and uh hopefully we can see more with
this we appreciate your time
all right thank you guys uh so uh that's
tag team right there